willing I have children I will not be
giving them this no matter how hard they
cry fall off the floor at the Ralphs I'm
not this is not happening in my household
we're swapping some snacks today let's start
tasting round one round one I'll go first okay
in Latino culture typically after you eat you have
a little cafe a little coffee after you eat my mom
would not let me have coffee were you allowed
to have coffee no as a kid okay see I feel like
that's a universal thing but for us my mom what do
I see I'm gonna stay short yes that was it you're
gonna remain short that was the that was the rumor
so I kind of feel like because I would sneak a lot
of coffee I feel like I like stunted Myself by a
little bit my arms like are a little bit longer I
swear if you stand up like I had long arms okay
you'd like to blame that on the coffee because
I did sneak a lot of coffee as Fair Theory oh my
God oh my God no you think it is aloe vera juice
it tastes like green Jello it's surge have
you heard of it no I've never heard of this
it looks like something from like the Toy Story
Cinematic Universe it was like this 90s soda pop
okay soda pop who says soda I guess you do
apparently I'm like really everyone's like
wow she's old so I heard it has like double
the caffeine which makes total sense because
whenever we would have it we would just be
kind of like all like jittery like at PE and
like you know we couldn't even like focus in
class is there any more of this can I have it
I mean oh my gosh your own my very own take
me back take me back the notes of next one
my mom didn't let me have what is this this
is so wasteful like where's the crust she was
like if you want me to do that like I'll push
the sides down for you and still make you eat
the crust you know yeah oh my God it's not that
deep you know let me show you what I brought today
Donuts I could not have Donuts name so
it's really close to a Krispy Kreme all
these kids are bringing Krispy Kremes for
their birthdays and what am I bringing I'm
bringing these Mexican wedding cookies it's
not my wedding it was never my wedding that
was what my mom would make for me to
bring to class Cheers Cheers all right
oh my God this is like taking me back can
I have something I was gonna say can I try
yours let's swap on top of the swap how about
that all right mom look at me oh this one is
like key lime pie Eat My Pie slay if I had
children I would not deny them the pleasure
of a donut or an uncrustable no of course it
was rough watching kids have that and not me
let's do it I'm traumatized you were
never into Rice Krispies the homemade
version one thousand yeah I agree like
having a homemade one versus the wrapped
one it's a game changer it is have you
had a Rice Krispie treats cereal girl
that was the best thing in the world to
me drop into a split come back up yes it
is so good that expression before what um
what is happening okay what I mean I'm
gonna start using that that's the effect
of Rice Krispie treats cereal I like
how they had to give you a fork for that
okay so if yours doesn't need a utensil
maybe mine was okay okay I'm excited oh
oh my God wait was this little with the Penguin
on it yes yes this must have been your favorite
thing ever I've never had it done oh my God
oh my God I still haven't had it what is this
right what is that that's a brownie my mom
would be like do you not want to poop oh
is that too much but now I really
want to try it okay what is it good
chicken nugget like I'm gonna tear up that was
nasty that wasn't bad the mac and cheese right
um this is like Kraft macaroni and cheese
but you know as a Mexican I'm very
picky on my corn because I like
a steam chili powder cheese that's not a chicken
nugget I don't know what I'm eating can I have
that surge to wash it down real quick this is
terrible like right search yellow five I'm like
willing I have children I will not be
giving them this no matter how hard they
cry fall off the floor at the Ralphs I'm
not this is not happening in my household
stop
let's do it oh shots
oh my gosh White Rabbit creamy candy so when
you open it show us what you I already I would
go like this okay oh and then there's paper
do you eat the paper you eat the paper I love
eating paper it like melts in your mouth
I'm like Mom I want candy she's like you
want candy eat my rabbit did you ever own a
white rabbit we did yeah I only heard of the
hard-hitting questions here it was kind of
very like claw I've always wanted to have it
but my mom said they'd die within like two days
so I apparently they don't but that's just what
you told me another thing my mom wouldn't
let me have that's another a rabbit can I
um yes reveal let's see what we have another candy
okay okay my mom's favorite candy is Almond Joy I
was not a big candy person growing up think about
it you'd go to the store getting Halloween candy
all the candy is gone except for this except
for the Almond Joy listen I was onto something
I was onto something did I just buy it at first
it's one of those things you kind of let it sit
in your mouth and it softens over time it's
kind of a thing all the way commit commitment
let's let it sit okay I mean as
a kid does that look appealing
I don't know why I treated it like that
just the initial change is kind of like
pulling on what used to but I'm kind
of liking this note it just kind of
tastes like sweet and condensed milk that's
accurate I agree with you on that [Music]
okay I know this is weird weird but I need
to talk about this most people don't trust
the government I don't trust lettuce
what about now as an adult I don't I
don't eat it I like Romaine but I was
just like is this for my white rabbit
or I don't know like what's happening
I'm confused yeah it's a gift [Music]
what is that now this is traumatic okay what is
this it looks like rocks or something that you
put in like your hamster's cage like for them look
both of these go perfectly in a hamster cage where
is our White Rabbit legit bring out the bunny
right now it's called grape nuts but interestingly
it doesn't contain like grapes or nuts grapes
like raisins or nuts it's like barley and wheat
this is what's not gonna let you poop for days no
that's what my mom thought would help right I hope
they're not giving this to you dry that's going
to be hard to take down they look down they looked
out for you because I thought they were gonna
do you like how you did me with this roommate
I wasn't trying to do that to you
it's okay we'll get through it I'm
like genuinely afraid of eating this
tastes like the Earth you know I mean
I love lettuce I love like it I
like vegetables it's just I mean
I don't know why when you made that
face I made that face how was it
I think it's even more strange that they were able
to find this like who is still eating this I was
gonna ask for a spoon but I was like nah pass it
genuinely feels like there's rocks in my mouth I
took a really big bite why because I'm dumb I
don't know I don't know why you did that yeah
and then maybe wash it down with this girl no but
anyway there you go it's like wheat and barley
I'm gonna cry it's so nasty look at that that's a
hate crime any other show like does for housewives
like sometimes they would like poison a husband
s legit let's please let's go to the next one I
can't do this anymore this is the last final snap
yes that our parents would want to push on to us
nagariah cracker nuts coated peanuts
roasted peanuts and like there's like this
crunchy shell on top but this was my mom's
way of like I wanted like Cheeto pups or something
fun she'd be like go in the cupboard and get the
nagaraya but I would eat it I did like the garlic
flavor but I would just like suck the outside and
then I would throw the rest of it out okay I feel
like this one isn't that bad come through come on
cucumbers this is my mom's favorite
snack it's something she's watching
reality TV she's eating this she's
watching Law and Order she's eating
this like this is her go-to snack another
fun fact about me is I don't like cucumber
it came through with the garlic it did it's really
good I would eat this get another one and kind of
like as you get it like roll like roll it between
your fingers let me see your fingers what I'm
gonna say listen this is the best part that's the
best part oh my God that is amazing right I would
just go through and just say touch it from Flavor
down to like like all like the entire finger that
was really like a spiritual journey for me
wasn't it that was really good anyway it's
my mom I feel like I should be looking at you for
the reaction because I I like cucumbers this might
have changed my life I might like cucumbers
now wait a lot as of today I'm going really
can we bring that Romaine back I think we can
try that why not that's different there's E
coli involved oh my gosh oh my gosh okay sorry
that wasn't that bad mom I think you were onto
something here I might owe you an apology well
we had things that we never thought we would get
the chance to eat maybe some were disappointing
some really want us over Mom you write about Kid
Cuisine you were kind of right about the Cucumbers
kid Cuisines were like I'm there with you mom that
that was terrible thanks for looking out
love you Mom Mom you're the best foreign
[Music]